so over 40 000 members across Network  Rail and the 14 train operating  companies  will take a series of 48-hour strikes on  the 13th and 14th and 16th and 17th of  December and then again on the January  the 3rd and 4th and the 6th and 7th  there will also be an overtime ban  across the railways of all of our  members from the 18th of December until  the 2nd of January meaning that we'll be  taking continuous industrial action for  more than four weeks  despite  every effort made by our negotia is it  is clear now that the government is  directly interfering in our attempts to  reach a settlement  the union suspended previous strike  action in good faith to allow for  intensive negotiations to resolve the  dispute  yet Network railers failed to make an  improved offer on jobs paying conditions  for our members during the last two  weeks of talks